[Musik]
schon wieder liegt der vom sterben das
hat er nicht getan im kino la la land
jetzt mit der jazz im sterben der satz
fällt zumindest in ein biopic des
kanadischen regisseurs luc ponty blue
heißt es geht um den berühmten jazz
trompeter chet baker der damals der
james dean des cf genannt wurde wieder
nach haus war in nehmen den zuschauer
umfragen manchmal in der publikumsgunst
verdächtig vor vielen leuten die für uns
heute zu den ganz ganz großen des jazz
der jazz trompeter miles davis und lässt
wir treffen ihn drogenabhängig am ende
seiner kräfte mit wahnvorstellungen
einem italienischen gefängnis wird dann
von einem hollywood produzenten
herausgeholte er sein leben zu erfüllen
will
er scheitert daran dass becker an
zusammen mit der hauptdarstellerin des
films gleich zwei seiner frauen spur
entdeckt hat
holen sie kommen raus aus dem diner
freund also zusammengeschlagen
es passt drogendealer ihm aufgelauert
haben und versuchen zu vergessen und das
ist das ende für ein trompeter das ist
eine für ein trompeter und verbände
natürlich auch eine schauspielerin wird
auf eis gelegt die beiden sitzen da er
liegt im krankenhaus zimmer und haben
nichts auseinander und was sie
voneinander haben woran vor gericht was
sie voneinander haben
er fing dieser verpflichtet werden noch
nicht vorgestellt mein name ist baker
ich bin einer der größten trompete
meiner generation
es geht mir
unglaublich vielen chf in diesem winter
ein weißen der sich hat messen lassen
müssen mit übergroßen
diese gelassenheit davies geht immer
wieder auch um diese konfrontation die
man kennen muss um wirklich viel von den
services
was hat man von diesem film wenn man
nicht so viel über die es weiß oder so
viel über jazz wissen will dann hat man
einiges in horb wirklich ergreifend als
dieser chet baker zurück in seine musik
kämpft halten sie einfach durch und
vermeiden sie ihren nun zu belasten der
eine gewisse platte bekommt und es gibt
eine szene in der er sitzt dann in der
badewanne und hält sich die trompete
immer wieder an die lippen und drückt an
seinen künstlichen zehn herum und
versucht zu spielen und blut und es
warten lassen
furchtbar anzusehen ich weiß nicht ob
der film was für schätze ist es kein
film in dem verzeichnis irgend etwas
tiefer gehen hier gesagt wird es ist ein
film sicherlich für romantiker für leute
sie sich etwas über die kraft in die und
etwas über die grenzen der kraft der
liebe im kino erzählen lassen
[Musik]